when looking at demonology and the
various figures that appear all
throughout religion there is one female
figure one name more so than any other
that has transcended across numerous
cultures and even to this day still
routinely appears as a character in all
sorts of popular culture and that name
is Lilith
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
some of you may remember in the video
discussing the succubus Lilith was a
name that appeared as an early example
the most common description of Lilith
however is as a demon of the night
seductive and sexual in nature but also
deadly and if that wasn't enough she
also waits until the cover of darkness
to steal babies and young children this
concept can be traced all the way back
to ancient Mesopotamian religion where
there once existed a figure known as
Lamaze - the daughter of the sky God our
new to some she was an evil goddess to
others a demon a monster that plagued
women during childbirth one that would
steal their children suck out their
blood and marrow only to gnaw on the
bones that remain the mothers themselves
are not safe from lemaster and neither
were their unborn children as she could
make women miscarry as one of the most
terrifying demons in Mesopotamian myth
her actions were not just limited to
pregnant women she would drink the blood
and eat the flesh of men she infected
ones dreams until only nightmares were
left wherever she went she was followed
by sickness disease and death with these
stories of lamashtu we can definitely
see a parallel with creatures such as
vampires and succubi today many think of
lilith as the first wife of Adam who
rebelled and was later replaced by Eve
this idea stems from the book of Genesis
the very first book in both the Hebrew
Bible and the Old Testament Genesis one
details the creation of the universe as
well as everything inside of it it says
that God created the heavens the earth
vegetation animals and lastly mankind in
his own image to rule over what he had
created what's important to note is that
Genesis 1 states that he created both
man and woman at the same time Genesis 2
is very similar discussing the creation
of the universe but it differs in
regards to the creation of man and woman
here a man was created first not wanting
his creation to be alone
God sent man into a deep slumber and
took from him a rib which he would use
to create the first woman so essentially
you have two contradicting accounts of
our creation one right after the other
too many the Word of God is sacred and
therefore cannot contradict itself this
led to scholars explaining the
differences between Genesis 1 and 2 as
describing two separate events rather
than two accounts of the same event this
in turn created the need for a story
that explained these differences which
would be found in what is referred to as
Midrash the explanation here is that God
needed to create woman twice once with
man and then again from man the woman in
the first story isn't identified in
Genesis but would eventually be known as
Lilith the woman in the second story is
who we know from the Bible as Eve so if
you've ever heard the story of Eve being
created from Adam's rib that is the
story found in Genesis 2 lilith also
appears in the talmud and these accounts
are far less ambiguous than what we see
in genesis she appears here a total of
four times and is never referred to as
Adams wife where the Babylonians
referred to Lilu as winged male demons
the talmud speaks of Lilith or Lily - as
a demon with wings and the face of a
woman it says that a man sleeping in a
house alone may be seized by Lilith it
said that she collected the semen of men
while they slept in order to create more
demon offspring which again can be seen
as one of the earliest examples of the
succubus
she is then also associated with several
demons one of these be in the a Grethe a
demon of the Knights who preys on
children and the vulnerable so far we
can see two distinct images of Lilith
the woman and the demon but what
happened in this middle ground from when
she was created all the way up until she
became a demon stories explaining this
were developed in much more detail
around the Middle Ages so from the 5th
century to the 15th
details of Ben Sira and the alphabet of
serac are pieces of work that echo a
sentiment that many scholars and scribes
seem to agree upon when Adam and Lilith
were created neither one of them wanted
to submit to the other two somnus
justement who assumed the dominant role
in the relationship whereas others took
this to mean neither one wanted to
assume the bottom position during sex as
it was a sign of subservience with
neither one of them willing to
compromise lilith then fled the Garden
of Eden out loud she then pronounced
God's real name and in doing so she
instantly became a winged demon when the
Angels pursued her in the hopes of
bringing her back she told them she had
no intention of returning as punishment
for her disobedience the three angels
who found her promised to kill 100 of
her demon children every day her purpose
now was only to cause illness and
sickness to the infants of others
whenever a child was born she would
claim dominion over that child for eight
days if they were boy and 20 if they
were a girl with this they came only one
compromise whenever she saw the name
over any of these three angels inscribed
on a medallion or an amulet that child
would be left alone there isn't much
surviving material from the Akkadian
Empire that allows for an in-depth
analysis of Lamaze - or they Lily - in
relation to Lilith but what we do know
from the Babylonians and Sumerians is
that all of these creatures were fairly
similar and it's not a huge stretch to
say that they may have influenced Lilith
story in some way the lack of
information regarding her origin is made
up for by how popular her story was the
Middle Ages mark this period like no
other with numerous tellings and
interpretations depictions of her varied
from a beautiful woman to a more
sinister demon and some even saw her as
the snake in the Garden of Eden who
tempted Eve with the forbidden fruit as
one final act of revenge
as time went on there were folktales at
so Lilith as a demon Queen and thus
related to Asmodeus who many consider to
be the king of demons
Asmodeus been mentioned in the book of
Tobit the talmud and numerous other
scriptures means it's not really a huge
surprise that lilith and he were paired
together as the mother and father of
demons together they had thousands of
demon children and traveled from village
to village causing chaos and destruction
in some stories she's also closely
linked of Samael who himself is a rather
odd character some teachings in the
cabal go as far to say that Lilith was
Sam Isles consort and that it was not
God who created her but instead Samael
who made himself a demon wife who filled
the role later intended for Eve he also
gave her a host of demonic children one
of these being Asmodeus who we mentioned
earlier throughout all these stories
there are three main signs to Lilith the
woman who rebelled against God and Adam
which is the side we see the least of
the seductive demoness who plagued the
dreams of men to grow her demonic family
and lastly the monster who preyed upon
pregnant women devouring their children
when I first read about Lilith I
immediately drew some parallels between
her and some of the creatures we see in
Greek mythology when you think of an
odious and foul-smelling bird-like
creature the harpies certainly come to
mind but so do the sirens who have a
more seductive nature however the
character who closest resembles and
embodies these three signs of Lilith is
Lamia these three stages almost mirrored
in her story she begins as a regular
woman who falls victim to lust and as a
result her children are killed as a
punishment
she's then transformed into a monster in
some telling is Lamia and the Lamia of
vampiric demons who feed off the blood
of young handsome men there are also
versions of this story where instead of
young men she hunts for children forever
seeking revenge for those she had lost
much like Lilith Lamia was intended to
be a cautionary tale a boogeyman like
figure although her story is much less
about rebellion and more so the dangers
of lust
honestly stories of Lilith are rather
confusing it's only really because of
stories from Midrash and other scholars
that we can even draw a link between the
demon and the wife of Adam however this
hasn't really harmed her representation
in popular culture there are a few
references that I remember but looking
into it further I was definitely
surprised that the number of books
movies games and TV shows that her name
actually appears in fans of Chronicles
of Narnia may or may not know that the
White Witch is actually a descendant of
the first wife of Adam which in this
case is of course Lilith in the TV show
True Blood and the movie 30 Days of
Night
Lilith appears as the name of a vampire
and this is honestly quite a common
trend when she does appear it's either
as a succubus or a vampire
old school supernatural fans may
remember her as the first human to be
tempted by Lucifer into becoming a demon
speaking of Lucifer and that show she's
also referred to as the mother of demons
one that I missed that actually has
quite an interesting take on Lilith
story is the Fifth Element which sounds
quite weird to say considering it's a
futuristic sci-fi Lilu is portrayed in a
similar way to Adam's first wife and her
speaking ancient Aramaic now makes more
sense than when I watched the movie as a
kid instead of destroying humanity she
actually ends up saving it turning the
original story on its head when it comes
to video games if you've played anything
remotely populated slightly you've seen
her name somewhere as it appears in
final fantasy Borderlands Diablo
Darksiders Devil May Cry and many many
more personally I think Lilith has an
interesting story regardless of how
confusing and stitched together the
original references may be whether you
see it as a fall from grace or a
rebellious uprising it's a very
universal concept which is why I think
it's referenced so often today it may
also have something to do with the
occult and modern fantasy going hand in
let me know what you think about her
story and whether you noticed how often
she appears today if you have enjoyed
the artwork animations for this video
they were created by the very talented
mando Teresa who also made the Medusa
artwork in animations so if you'd like
to check her work out there'll be a link
to her YouTube channel on other socials
in the description of this video I am
also excited to announce that due to
popular demand many of these episodes
will soon be in podcast form on all the
major platforms so if that's something
you're interested in keep an eye out for
that as always I've been your host
mythology in fiction explained
[Music]
[Music]